welcome back to our ET suite here at
comic-con you know tomorrow will smith
margot robbie jared leto and the cast of
Suicide Squad will hit town so they can
give fans a little sneak peek of their
movie but why--wait ET has an exclusive
look behind the scenes right now
the Suicide Squad or criminals brought
together to try and do good
no one is cooler than Will Smith as
Deadshot there's the honor among thieves
there's a part of him that a Deadshot is
thinking maybe I might have made a wrong
turn or two in his life
then there's that twisted Joker Jared
Leto oh I didn't realize that the Joker
was 75 years old I mean the story of the
Joker I never thought in a million years
that I would have the chance to play a
role like this he hooks up with Margot
Robbie as crazy Harley Quinn Harley
Quinn nice to meet you
dr. hollien Quinzel was working at
Arkham Asylum she's his psychiatrist and
that's where she met Joker and fell for
Joker and then born out of that was
transformation into Harley Quinn despite
the fact that she looked like a demented
cheerleader it was very frightening to
come within an inch of her but at the
same time a vulnerability maybe bad guys
but I think it is a good
viola day this is Amanda Waller and we
got to say it is cool to see these
ladies in such strong roles like Cara
Delevingne
deliciously wicked enchantress please
don't touch me I don't really remember
seeing a movie where the women have got
such important roles they were always
the kind of the this sidekick or the
kind of love interest
I remember reading and I was like oh my
god the girls have the best lines I'm
known to be quite back things
I'm just forewarning you we sort of
landed on the separation between being a
bad guy and being evil it's not a movie
about good versus evil it's a movie
about bad versus evil